الان معنا من الخليل الدكتور بلال الشوبكي
رئيس قسم العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الخليل
نرحب بك دكتور بلال
الشوبكي خسائر تعلن عنها او يعلن عنها
بالاحرى الجيش الاسرائيل تاثير هذا البعد
العسكري هذه الخسائر هذه الحصيله التي
توصف في اسرائيل بال الثقيله وصفها
بنيامين نتنياهو بحد ذاته بانها كارثه في
العمل العسكري في في اسرائيل تاثير كل ذلك
على المسار السياسي على مسار هذه الحرب
على مستقبل نتنياهو بحد
ذاته صباح الخير يعني في بدايه هذه الحرب
شهدنا حمله من التجييش داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي ضد قطاع غزه على اعتبار انه
يعني تم يعني التوضيح للمجتمع الاسرائيلي
بانه هذه الحرب هي حين وجوديه و لابد من
ان يكون هناك اجراء حاسم من الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ضد الفلسطينين في قطاع غزه
لذلك في بدايه الحرب برايي كان هناك
استعداد نفسي لدى المجتمع الاسرائيلي
لتقبل فكره ان يكون هناك خسائر في صفوف
يعني جن الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بال من
الحساسيه المفرطه تاريخيا لدى الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بوقوع اي خسائر على المستوى
البشري نيه التجييش كانت عاليه جدا بان
الانقلاب الذي حصل برايي في عدم وجود
انجازات مترافق مع الاثمان التي يدفعها
الجيش الاسرائيلي في قطاع غزه يعني هذه هي
المعضله المساله لا تقرا لوحدها ان هناك
خسائر بشريه في صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي
وانها خسائر غير متفقه من اي انجازات يمكن
ان تقدم لهذا المجتمع ولذلك اثرها سيكون
كبير لكن الاثر ليس اني بمعنى ان الاثر
الاني للخسائر البشريه هو اثر مضمر لانه
عاده ما يزيد من حاله التجييش يعني الان
لو ذهبنا مثلا الى كيفيه تفاعل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي مع هذه الخساره التي حصلت في
السنوات الاخيره وكيفيه التغبير به الاراء
سنجد انها يمينيه متشدده متطرفه حتى يعني
تكاد لا تميز بين وسط ويمين ويسار في
المجتمع الاسرائيلي لانه في في اللحظات
ولكن بما انك اشرت الى الشارع الاسرائيلي
هذا الشارع ينتظر من صناع القرار تلك
الوعود التي تم تقديمها فيما يتعلق بهذه
الحرب بتحقيق اهداف هذه الحرب وانها
ستتواصل حتى تحقيق الاهداف والجميع يعلم
اهداف الاهداف الاسرائيليه من وراء هذه
الحرب الا ان النتيجه حتى الان هو فشل
يتلوه فشل اخر وخسائر في الارواح كيف يمكن
ان يقابل الشارع الاسرائيلي كل
ذلك هذه هي الخطوه اللاحقه بمعنى نحن نشهد
شارعا اسرائيليا يتفاعل بطريقه يعني
متغيره بشكل تدريجي وملحوظ التغيير يعني
كما في البدايه كان الشارع مديج بشكل كبير
الان هذا الشارع يسال حاله يعني سؤال كبير
جدا هل هذه الاثمان التي تدفع من دماء
ابنائنا يمكن ان يقابلها انجاز حقيقي
بدونم الجمع داخل اسرائيل
الانعا الناطقين الرسميين وبنين نتنياهو
وجلا انه لا يوجد تحقيق لاي انجاز لم يتم
استعاده المحتجزين جزء منهم الا من خلال
المفاوضات ولم يتم القضاء على حركه حماس
بل ان الحدث الذي يتم الان ي الاستخدام
للتدليل على ان حركه حماس ما زالت موجوده
بعد كل هذه الاشهر من الحرب على قطاع غزه
وبالت ل الروايات الاسرائيليه التي قدم
خلال الفتره الماضيه وانا هنا يعني اذكركم
بالكثير من المؤتمرات اليه التي قدمها
جاري وقال استطعنا ضرب البنيه التنظيميه
استطعنا تفكيك جزء من السلسله التنظيميه
وصلنا الى كذا وكذا من يعني تحدث ه هل
يمكن توصيف كل هذه التصريحات ان كان من
نتنياهو ومن غيره من صناع القرار
والقيادات العسكريه في اسرائيل على انها
تبريرات في هذه ال المرحله واذا كانت
تبريرات ما هي قراءتكم ل التبريرات
الاسرائيليه المتعلقه بهذه الحرب التي
تواصل 108 ايام اليوم تحديدا دكتور
بلال هي وصلت قناعه لدى شريحه من المجتمع
الاسرائيلي ولا اقول كل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي الشريحه المجتمع الاسرائيلي
وصلت لديهم قناعه وهذه هي التطور الثالث
بمعنى في بدايه يعني في في المرحله
السابقه كانوا يقولوا انه اثمان دون نتائج
لكن الان الثمن الذي يدفع من اجل مصلحه
سياسيه ضيقه لبعض الفئات سواء كنا نتحدث
عن الائتلاف اليميني الموسع او عن بنيامين
تنياه لوحده ولذلك نعم هم يقراون على على
شكل حتى يتجاوز مساله التبرير هي عمليه
يعني استغلال من نتنياهو لهذه الحرب
وللحالات الراهنه من اجل المضي قدما فيها
والاستمرار فيها بحيث يطيل عمر الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
و يقرا ذلك
يعني الحدث الذي يقول ان هناك ق في سوق
الجيش الاسرائيلي تغطيه الاكثر هي
للمسيرات التي تقف امام مقر اقامه بنيامين
نتنياهو يعني ان التحول الان تم في
العقليه الاسرائيليه بان سبب المعضل الان
ليس فقط يعني مرتبط باداء اليش الاسرائيلي
ولا في الاثمان التي يدفعها ولا في عدم
تحقيق الانجازات وانما في محاوله استغلال
كل هذا الحدث من قبل بنيامين نتنياهو
للبطء يعني ان الدماء
الاسترا هذا ما يجمع عليه كما ذكرت دكتور
بلال اذا يجمع المراقبون والكثيرون على ان
اطاله امد هذه الحرب المستفيد الوحيد منها
هو بنيامين نتنياهو ولكن السؤال على ماذا
يعول نتنياهو فيما يتعلق
ببقائه
هو يستثمر عده مسائل يعني بنيامين نتنياهو
لو لم يكن يملك بعض النقاط لم يستطاع
المضي قدما حتى هذه اللحظه هو يستثمر اولا
يعني اعتقاده بان بيني جانس وايزن كوت
بالرغم من انهم يختلف يختلفان معه في كثير
من الامور الا ان انسحابهما الان من مجلس
الحرب الاسرائيلي يستل من قبل صومهما على
انها ادانه لهذين الرجلين بكونهما من الجن
اسرائيل الان في حاله حرب وبالتالي يمكن
ان يظهر يعني هذان الرجلان شيئا من الضعف
اذا ما انسحب لانه حتى الجمهور المؤيد
لايزن كوت وبيني جانس يريد منهما التغيير
من بمعنى الذهاب الى خارج مجلس الحرب فيه
احساس بالضعف والعجز عن تقديم اي شيء داخل
مجلس الحرب المساله الثانيه التي يعتمد
عليها بني من نتنياهو ايضا ادراكه الى ان
اليمين الاسرائيلي وصلته
ارقام الراي وبالمناسبه هذه المراحل
الفريده التي تصبح فيها نقاط الضعف عند
بنيامين نتنياهو تتحول الى نقطه قوه ضعف
بنيامين نتنياهو في جماهيريته لكن هو ليس
الوحيد الضعيف الان الائتلاف اليميني كله
القوى اليمينيه كلها ضعيفه الليكو كله
ضعيف وبالتالي
اكوت اذا ما ذهب الى اجراء اي تغييرات او
الائتلاف الحاكم اذا ما ذهب الى اجراء اي
تغييرات لن يعود الى الحكم وهو مطمئن الى
هذه الحاله كما هو محتاج الى الاتلاف
اليميني كما
هو اضيف الى ما ذكرت دكتور بلال اضيف الى
ما ذكرت مطالبات زعيم المعارضه لبيد
باجراء انتخابات مبكره وتحديد موعد لاجراء
هذه الانتخابات ولكن مدى واقعيه هذا الطرح
الان يعني لابد من خارج
الحكومه والمعارضه من المتوقف ان ينادي
بمثل هذا الامر وحزب العمل نادى بامكانيه
حجب الثقه وتش في هذا الموضوع هذه خطوات
مهمه اهميتها ليس في مدى فعاليتها
السياسيه اهميتها في كسر الق اليه التي
بنيت امام المجتمع الاسرائيلي منذ السابع
من اكتوبر هوي تحرم الحديث في السياسه
يعني الحديث دائما في الامن في المه
القوميه الان الكسر هذه الحواجز الحديث
بال السياسه س تدريجي وصو الى المرحله
التي لم يكن احد يظن فيها ان في اليوم
الثاني اللي غزه في اليوم التالي لحركه
حماس يح فيها الان عن المستوى الاسرائيلي
والمستوى الفلسطيني والمستوى الامريكي
اليوم التالي ل بنيمين نتنياهو
ولذلك ما يجري حقيقه الان داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي هو تطوير نوعا ما للراي العام
بحيث يتكتل اشكاليه الراي العام
الاسرائيلي او جزء من الراي العام
الاسرائيلي الذي عارض اولويات مجلس الحرب
انه كان شار يعوني من الميو يعني لا يوجد
نقطه يتمركز حولها هذا الشارع بحيث يؤدي
الى احداث ضغط على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه وجود اواق معارضه وجود قيادات
من المعارضه تتبنى هذا الشارع من شانها ان
يجعل الشارع اكثر صلاب ومتكتف في مقابل
الشارع اليميني الصلب لذلك وجودد وجود
ايهود باراك بالرغم من انهما يعني غير نا
فيسان الان بشكل كبير لكن الوجود الاهم هو
في
انسحاب الاسرائيلي لا يوجد حتى هذه اللحظه
يعني يعني سوى مؤشرات بسيطه على هذا
الموضوع لكن في حال انسحب نتاجا لتطور
التاف يمكن ان يكون هو التكتل الابرز حوله
وبالتالي يقود الى الضغط على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لانها ل تكون قد سفق في حنا
بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك نقطه يتخوف منها
بنيمين نتنياهو ان يحدث تس في ال 64 مقعد
التي تضمن استقرار الحكومه بمعنى انه 64
مقعد ليست 44 مقعد مضمونه 100% لانه هناك
حاله تذمر داخل حزب الليكود وهناك حاله
تذمر حتى من جنت الذي يتواجد بصفته في
يعني من حزب الليكود في مجلس الحرب
الاسرائيلي وكما تعلمون صحيح انه يؤيد
العمليه العسكريه ويتفق جزئيا في بعض
الامور مع بني نتنياهو لكن خلال الاسبو
الماضي كنا نناقش الازمه العميقه ما بين
جالانت وما بين بنيامين نتنياهو وهي ازمه
سابقه لسابع من اكتوبر وممتده الى هذه
المرحله وجلت من الشخصيات التي لم تكن
اصلا من صلب حزب الليكود وجاء من خارج
الحزب
ولدينا ايضا تجربه طويله مع شخصيات
اسرائيليه انتقلت من حزب الى اخر نتاجا
لظروف سياسيه لذلك بنيامين نتنياهو ربما
يثير تخوفه جزء من الدائره اليمينيه اكثر
من تخوفه من اطاد خارج المعارضه مثل حزب
العمل خارج الحكومه الاسرائيليه مثل حزب
العمل او غيرهم من التغيرات
ال هذه الصور التي نناقشها الان التي تاتي
من قطاع
غزه يعني تدفع بهذا
الاتجاه باتجاه ان يكون هناك عمليه يعني
تخير للشم الاسرائيلي تحتاج هذه المساله
الى فتره يعني الى عمليه تكن ليست المساله
مساله يعني في بعض التقديرات وبعض
القراءات كانت تظن انه ربما بالامكان في
لحظه ما ان يح التحول الجذري لكنها مساله
تراكميه شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور بلال
الشوبكي رئيس قسم العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه الخليل شكرا جزيلا لك